[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far millions of challengers not one
winner we challenge our fans find one
tiny misstep they can I know why they
still try we're perfect certainly any
who tonight a fan named Ryan says he
thinks he's caught a mistake he says it
happened during a recent comedy sketch
we did about Andy's pet elephant so
what's your little skit with the and
email
[Music]
and one particular thing really caught
my eye
[Music]
you know last time I checked people
don't shower like that
[Music]
all right I'm sorry are you booing Ryan
or me I got confused there I think
people here might suspect that we funded
been caught making yeah I think they
probably do yeah well guess what Ryan if
that's even your name who is Conan
anyway you are dead wrong
old pal that was no mistake and he knew
not to get into that shower naked
that's because Andy knows what all
animal experts know elephants react
violently to the sight of male genitalia
yeah special intimidating you walked
into my shot sorry
I didn't expect that anyway don't
believe me they do they react violently
to the sight I'll genitalia penises are
a Maxima yeah that's a big word you
don't believe me check out this footage
shot at the recently closed
quanto Game Reserve and nudist colony in
South Africa good morning Timbo how are
we today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah that's why yep that's footage that
can't be faked so the challenge still
stands
you think you've spotted an error on our
show reporting at team koco.com / ha ha
I found an error we'll sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro we'll be right back
you